our Amazon talking to directors about
this straight to cinema Stargate movie
and
do I have a few names for you welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so I promised you some really really
interesting news about Stargate in the
last couple of videos where I've been
able to tell you some really interesting
stuff about what's going on behind the
Iron Curtain the Amazon we believe that
we are getting really really close now
to an announcement regarding Stargate
and this cinematic movie that would kind
of being promised that we're getting
lots and lots of talk online about this
now and actors talking about it ex
producers of the show Joseph malozi Etc
talking about it
it looks like this really is gonna
happen but if they are doing a cinematic
movie you don't necessarily need a
showrunner you need a director now
previous movies what they tend to do is
when they get to the point of
announcement they tend to like to have
sort of like that main actor the star
the name that goes on the poster and
they have to have the director the
director will join very early on they
will work hand in hand with writers Etc
and the development team that are
actually going to decide really the
direction of the project the director is
almost always on board really really
early and when they're on board early
and they actually do get grips of the
project that tends to be when you get
the best movies TV shows Etc so we don't
necessarily need a showrunner we need a
director
and I've got three names for you now
according to my source over at MGM and
Amazon these directors have been very
informally approached already
um actually going back anything up to
six months ago for one of the names
that these directors have had multiple
conversations and that all three have
expressed different levels of Interest
so I'm not going to mess around anymore
I'm going to tell you who the names are
Joseph Kaczynski is the first director
and apparently the first person they
approached some time ago now why would
they approach the guy that directed the
biggest cinematic release if your name's
not James Cameron for the last few years
really probably the biggest cinematic
release other than Avatar since covid
I think that's a bit of a no-brainer
most recently kazinski did a movie for
Netflix with Chris Hemsworth and Miles
Teller keep that in mind for a second he
also has a bit of a Sci-Fi history he
did the Tron movie and he did the
Oblivion movie with Tom Cruise so enjoys
a bit of sci-fi
also there's an interesting connection
there as I mentioned Miles Teller who
did appear in spiderhead and also
appeared in Maverick that was a rumor
that we heard a long time ago that Miles
Teller was potentially being put up as
the actor to actually then appear in the
main role he'd have the Jack O'Neill
role if you'd like not literally they're
not recasting him don't get in the
comments but
the leader of whatever new team or
whatever project or whatever the movie
was going to be based around
it's very very interesting that several
months later we suddenly hear that the
director was possibly in contact with
Amazon even before Christmas about the
Stargate movie
and then Miles Teller name got added
this is a director that does seem to
work with like the same actors several
times these Works Tom Cruise a couple of
times he's worked for Miles Teller a
couple of times
so it doesn't surprise me then that his
name leaked why Miles Teller obviously
just appeared in Maverick Goose's son
did pretty well in that
he's one of those actors though that you
know him but you may not know his name
you know he's not like a thoroughbred
a-lister he might be perfect for
somebody that could jump between movies
and TV series for a wider Stargate
franchise and I've been telling you guys
for a long time that's the sort of actor
they wanted when Liam Hemsworth let them
down and he kept apparently arguing that
he wanted to produce the roles and
things
um but when he let them down and decided
to jump ship to
um The Witcher idiot
um the first name we hear after that was
Miles Teller and I've not heard any
actor's name since that have been
attached
Joseph Kaczynski for me is a distinct
possibility he has got a couple of
up-and-coming projects on his IMDb list
so that might slow things down a little
bit
but it's still very interesting name I
think he's a very good director he has a
good Thoroughbred in sci-fi and I
actually think he could bring something
really really interesting to the Sci-Fi
franchise the next game I'm going to
drop is Chris McKay now he is a director
that's actually worked with Amazon
before he recently did the Chris Pratt
movie The Tomorrow War he's also he also
recently did the Renfield movie which I
am dying to see
um I didn't get to go to the cinema for
a couple of different reasons to watch
it and the wife wasn't particularly Keen
to go
um it's now on um our Sky Cinema but
it's like 15 quid to watch it so I'm not
I'm not doing that I'll wait till it
goes on Sky Supermarket for you know
maybe a couple of good but it looks like
a really interesting movie I'd love to
know if you guys have seen Renfield get
in the comments tell me if it's any good
or not but this is a director that again
has a Sci-Fi Thoroughbred the moral war
was not a bad movie at all it was
cleverly put together it was very nicely
edited the special effects were decent
for straight to streaming movie and
actually I would give it a good solid 8
out of 10. so he's a name that I would
be very interested in I think he would
be a safe bet for Amazon Amazon know him
people there have worked with him and I
just think that that is an easy but safe
name to have in this little pot now I
can't tell you how many of these
conversations have had with Kaczynski I
have a little bit more information
because there's been several discussions
with McKay it seems that there has been
conversations but I don't know much more
than that the last name was a bit of a
wild card and when I saw it I have to
admit it stood out a little bit
Jordan peel now this guy is actually an
actor that you would know his face again
he's one of those actors who's done
loads of things over the years
but he very recently directed the movie
nope now last year that was pretty
critically acclaimed movie it did pretty
well at the box office as well
sci-fi movie full of lots of mystery I
know that Harris particularly loved this
film
he also did the movie us a couple of
years ago which was a horror movie very
high concept very strange film in lots
of the ways beautifully put together
John peel is one of those directors that
gets involved in every aspect of his
movies they're his films he really does
get involved in the scripts the
direction the photography everything
so when a John peel film comes out it's
a John peel film he's not got much on
his IMDb other than an Untitled John
peel movie
other than that he's got nothing
upcoming
so is that because he's been working
very heavily on the Stargate franchise
possibly now I have to admit looking at
the movies he's done in the past I
couldn't quite see what Amazon were
going with this I didn't think he would
be interested because it didn't sound
like the sort of thing he would do
but actually talking to a very close
friend of the channel and a really
really good source and matters like this
it would seem that possibly there are
reasons why John peel makes sense but
sadly at the moment I can't sing any
more than that but hopefully I'll be
able to at some time in the future all I
can tell you is I didn't believe this
and I thought it stuck out like a sore
thumb but after talking to the other
source all of a sudden
he might be the front runner or at very
least I can understand why he might be
very very tempted to get involved with
the Stargate franchise so
who do I actually think is in the lead
for this I actually think it's possibly
Kaczynski the only issue being is
whether they can get him to do it
because he probably is one of the most
in demand young directors in Hollywood
right now
so if Amazon can do a deal and they can
get him to maybe agree to a three movie
deal or something like that with TV
series intermixed
yeah I think he could be a very very
exciting name to have connected to the
Stargate franchise and a director that
really really could do the job very well
but to be honest all three of these
names interest me I think all three of
them could do a brilliant job I love
that all three of them have got a really
decent history of sci-fi and from a
couple of things I've heard all of them
might be very interested in something
like this
so guys get into the comments what do
you think about these three names are
they names that excite and interest you
or are you thinking I'd love somebody
else
get into the comments and tell me who
you'd love to see if you were suddenly
in charge of Amazon
what director would you choose get into
the comments tell me exactly what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification now you know what to do and
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]